nicknamed The Iceman he's a Finnish
racing driver for Ferrari in Formula One
he joined Ferrari in 2007 becoming the
highest paid driver with a salary of 51
million dollars his move to Ferrari saw
him win his first Formula One
Championship beating McLaren drivers
Lewis Hamilton and Fernando Alonso by
just one point he's Kimi raikkonen and
here at his top 10 rules for success
was there ever a time when you started
to doubt your ability can I still do
this no because I have probably gone
through quite a few times the same story
and you know obviously you always think
I know how can I get this sorted out and
you try and try many things when I get
the car as for my liking I can drive it
pretty well and fast so for myself I
want to make sure that
stage like that and we can do it every
single time when I drive out of the box
as out onto the podium comes the race
winner Kimi raikkonen takes the top step
for the first time in his formula one
career can me riking and comfortably
leads the world championship then with
16 points
Melbourne it was a little hard to tell
whether the new rules had played a part
here it was a perfect race really a
perfect day for Kimmy reichen and we
started with a 21 year old pole sitter
we finished with a 23 year old winning
the race it's all about the people I
mean it's all about all the people the
guys who who never see on the circuits
or TVs or anywhere you know at the
factory you hardly see them but we need
all of those and obviously we are we
have a very strong team boss now to to
run the whole whole team and putting
things in our order and like I said I
think it's all the people are working
well as a one team for Ferrari and
that's a big key for for for for the
problems that we had
[Applause]
[Music]
my plan
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there was always different options and
then we decided to all together to to
match this option so I mean of course
it's I worked with them three years so I
know the people and we had a lot of
relationship so in that way of course
when you when you change something it's
it's always a bit a bit funny in the
beginning but that's it's not the first
time and it's not the end of the world
seven
what a great moment Enzo Ferrari used to
say a win at Monaco is worth half a
world championship I think Jimmy Reagan
would settle for uh halving what a
championship we have unfolding in front
of us eight races in the next 11 weeks
it's gonna be a decisive phase of the
championship and this man is arriving in
it in a spectacular form and renov got
to do something about their rear tire
wear haven't they this is not the
toughest of the racetracks for that but
certainly uh they've got a deficit there
to McLaren so big thanks to Jensen
button for joining us in the commentary
box today we'll see him racing at the
Nurburgring in a week's time Kimmy
reichen had a hundred diamonds put into
his helmet by the Steinmetz Jewelers
this weekend he didn't need them though
to Sparkle around the streets of Monte
Carlo
Kimmy you have so many fans out there
why do you think that is what is it
about you that has caught the
imagination of the general public well I
have no idea obviously I'm not here to
try the police people or do it for
somebody else I do it for myself and I
do the things how I feel is the best for
me you're never gonna please everybody
and that's not my my job you know my
jumpers tried to do well in the racing
and you know I'm fortunate to have so
many good fans
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
basically if you become the F1 driver or
any top race driver you need to do quite
a lot of Fitness because it's part of
the lifestyle and you get used to it and
then you just feel better afterwards and
okay maybe on the time when you're doing
something in the gym it's not the most
noticed feeling sometimes but the doctor
which is it's awareness
thank you
thank you I always enjoy different
things with engine Motocross and I
actually started on that and then I
started to do a bit better and I still
didn't believe that I would never make
it to formula one because we didn't have
money and I just thought I'd do the cold
cuts as long as possible and then do
something else
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
if you try to be something that you are
not then obviously it's not going to
work for a long very well
I mean I don't think
you will enjoy your life if you just try
to make other people happy and not
[Music]
to what you feel is the right thing for
yourselves
[Music]
thank you
we hope to do well and of course I hope
to do better than last year on their
times I I miss them to win more races
and be more higher up fight for
Champions but that's how I am but is it
gonna happen and there's no no promises
on that we hope we can achieve those
results
we will work for those but we have to
first see that the car is good once we
start running it and I believe it should
be so uh
um try The Wind Rises and go from there
try to do the best that we can and
hopefully win much more risings than one
it's time for Kimmy reichen to celebrate
his World Championship win and what
better way to do it than to be on the
top step of the dice
[Music]
yeah
I never care really what people think so
if I if I don't finish the next rest I
think that I'm I'm a shot glass as bad
as that dress so you know I do my things
and if I'm happy about I'm doing that's
the main thing and I really don't care
if people are thinking differently now
than they thought that three three hours
ago so
makes no difference
[Music]
it's his seventh Podium finish of the
season but the first Podium let alone
Victory is his first podium in sixth
Grand Prix
and it's the first Podium for the team
here the instant team the whether you
call it Lotus Renault
time for the champagne shell oh it's not
champagne in this country of course sir
so the rose water shower that is uh
gonna be taking place here in the United
Arab Emirates
and uh still the opportunity to
pick the most of the moment get
photographs blasted across the world
thank you so much for watching now we
made this video because Christina Evan's
video editor and her husband Sam asked
him to do it hello Christina if you have
a video that you'd like to see made on a
famous entrepreneur write in the comment
below and maybe Evan will do it for you
I'd also love to know which of Kimi
raikkonen's top 10 rules you felt the
most connection to leave it in the
comments and we're going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon
thank you